my spirit animal is what Romanesco
broccoli it's that fractal pattern
Mother Nature is a pattern making
machine look at look at your
cardiovascular system tree roots that's
your blood vessels in your heart look at
that fractal pattern the studies show if
you look at fractal patterns in that
range you'll have a 60 reduction in
stress oh my God you're reorganizing
your brain yeah so we're fractal beings
the most recent studies that are being
done there's like a sir Pinsky triangle
some of the top Quantum researchers
they're trying to create a model that
that they could use as the model for
Quantum you know quantum mechanics guess
what they're doing to activate this this
triangle it's the fractal model that
they're using is that they put a photon
of light into the tip of it it
exponentially communicates with the
entire fractal pattern we're light
driven beings without the sun we're not
here without light energy without that
kind of wavelength and we're not here we
don't exist plants don't exist we're
toast